we've all gotten used to the idea of
electric cars now companies are trying
to get viable electric airplanes that
may sound like pie-in-the-sky but last
month the company's unum Aero took a big
leap forward when the charter flight
firm jet suite said it was purchasing up
to a hundred of zooms still to be
completed aircraft by 2022 and with
other major backers soon Amero is
considered best position to make it
faster cheaper and greener to fly I went
to zoo gnomes headquarters in Kirkland
Washington to see how they plan to do it
[Music]
west Matt Knapp sees nothing but
possibilities just over the horizon so
this is the plane as you envision it
right that's how we emission that is our
10 to 15 seat aircraft rolling down the
runway this is a very inexpensive to fly
airplane that makes you look like you
are a world-class business jet owner
Knapp co-founded Zune Amero along with
fellow aerospace engineer ashish kumar
the company is racing to build the first
ever electric propulsion airplane for
regional travel he would say what what
if you could do this and I go look at
the technology and then we come back
together and say wow we could do that
the tech startup began not in anyone's
garage but on the playground where their
wives and children met five years ago
he had no idea what he was getting into
zooms lofty ambition to rewrite aviation
history since 1980 government
deregulation has consolidated the
airline industry into a network of major
hubs all but grounding short haul
flights from 1980 up through 2010 the
airlines went from 20 to 80 seats you
got to fill all those seats you need a
big runway it makes lots of noise and
something you have a lot fewer airports
with services unum wants to change that
this is crazy what am I looking at every
one of those dots is an airport there
are over 13,000 airports in this country
and well over 4,000 those are currently
set up to allow commercial service of
the type we're talking
there's all these options and they're
sitting there and they're funded and we
just need to be using them Zune um is
designing its plane to take advantage of
those secondary regional airports under
a thousand miles apart a perfect range
for routes like San Francisco to Los
Angeles Kansas City to Oklahoma City
Atlanta to New Orleans or New York to
Boston door-to-door and let's say it was
a New York to Boston flight do you see
this cutting down your travel time as
well yes so if you were to take a sub
thousand mile trip today by air you
would probably spend three quarters of
that time actually on the ground driving
to the hub security baggage bells
check-in and sitting on the tarmac
taxiing waiting to take off right so
today you probably budget five hours
leaving home to get to a meeting in the
other city where we would say we could
drop that time behalf how by not you
know by avoiding the large shops smaller
airfields that are closer to where you
are leaving from and there are closer to
where you are learning at Kumar says not
relying on jet fuel will cut emissions
on average by 80 percent and slash the
price of a ticket which right now costs
several hundred dollars what would it
cost me on an aircraft like this well
our estimates would put it at about half
or a quarter of that Wow we don't set
prices obviously the airline set prices
what do you think from a cost standpoint
we can take that down by a factor of two
zouna estimates that a seat would cost
eight cents per passenger mile meaning
New York to Boston could be as cheap as
$25 each way
you're changing transportation in the
future forever yeah yeah
Graham Warwick is the technology
managing editor at Aviation Week he's
been covering the aircraft industry for
nearly 50 years this is probably the
most exciting period in aviation that I
have personally gone through Warwick
says Xun um is on the path to meeting
its goals technically their timeline
which is I think aiming for
certification in 2022 looks doable the
issue that they face is can the
regulatory timeline match the technical
technical development timeline after
years of delay electric propulsion is
now on the FAA radar the agency is
currently writing new standards to
certify this groundbreaking fleet of
airplanes zoom
then take those standards and do the
testing to prove to the FAA that their
system meets those standards last month
zoo name let CBS News see the first
round of tests on the electric and power
system that will eventually propel the
aircraft the company hopes to test their
system in the air sometime in 2019 five
years ago it would have looked black pie
in the sky but the push on the car side
to get to a reasonable range for a car
with 300 to 400 miles on a single charge
drove the battery technology to a point
where it becomes feasible to do a small
aircraft with battery power now we're
looking at the internal it's a nice
comfortable seating in there the big
green block on the left is the wing and
the batteries in the wing Xun um is
designing its first plane as a hybrid
battery powered with a gas turbine as a
backup the idea of having that much
battery power the amount that you'd need
mm-hmm is that the biggest I guess
hurdle to overcome
not at all the buses on the streets
right now they're running 2 3 4 times
what that airplane has Wow we have
basically a Tesla on each wing Xun um is
betting that between the replacement of
smaller conventional planes and more
people choosing to fly instead of drive
electric propulsion could generate a new
3 trillion dollar industry I think
basically you get them built and then
you have to have people just accept this
is ok in my form of Transportation now
the same way the first time airplanes
came out for sure but $25 for a flight I
mean sign me up
exactly